it has been an amazing season for the
Warriors and fans at home are beside
themselves but where exactly is home for
the NBA team it's here in Oakland also
home to the A's and the Raiders it's a
port city across the San Francisco Bay
known for its cultural diversity and
civil disobedience and of course this
but Oakland might also become known as a
city that can't keep its sports teams
all three major league teams are looking
to get out and while there's nothing
unique about teams moving the fact that
three teams that have as loyal of fan
base as they do here in Oakland are
considering leaving is enough to raise
an eyebrow after 44 years in Oakland the
Warriors are supposed to move back to
San Francisco by 2018 and a brand-new
state-of-the-art stadium will welcome
them but some Warriors fans however find
the move to be the dictionary definition
of disloyal Oracle's Oracle I wish they
would stay here because they're from
here I've been watching him for like
over 40 years this is where it all began
I mean if they win finals here it's just
a year I want the people who are the
working class people need to keep it at
home but as losing a sports team a bit
of a blessing in disguise there's tons
of money to be made in major league
sports from broadcasting rights to
concessions to merchandise and of course
ticket sales managers and teams are
raking it in and all of this fuels the
stadium myth the idea that a new stadium
or a new team brings economic
development and if the economy wins then
everyone wins right but that's not
exactly the case oftentimes taxpayers
and local communities lose out most
major league sports stadiums in this
country at least 64 of them are built
using public funding which is federal
tax free
these stadiums cost taxpayers millions
and they're not only getting that much
in return in the case of the Warriors
the team is not only leaving Oakland
fans for that sweet spot in San
Francisco but they're leaving them with
a 60 million dollar debt left over from
renovations made to the Oracle Stadium
back in the 90s taxpayer is going to be
paying that until the year 2027 sports
arenas can bring in a lot of people from
the city and outside of it but money is
only really being made during game
season and when there's a home game and
all that money is primarily going back
to the team with some of the businesses
directly surrounding the arenas making a
bit of profit too and really that's what
all of us comes down to Sports isn't
about loyalty it's about business and
business is about money and how to make
more of it teams move because managers
think that they can make more money
elsewhere and a good market for a sports
team is a market that shows up to the
games both the Raiders in the A's have a
die-hard loyal fan base but for over a
decade both teams have suffered from
some of the lowest attendance rates in
their leads so it doesn't matter that
the A's have won nine World Series
placing them third in baseball history
or the people here consider themselves
part of the Raider Nation legacy and
loyalty don't make money ticket sales do
and money is why the Warriors want to
move to San Francisco they don't have an
attendance problem far from it Oakland
has been loyal in its attendance of
warrior games even when the team wasn't
doing so hot team owners have a real
estate opportunity moving to San
Francisco is a property investment since
the city has some great tax breaks and
allows for development that Oakland just
doesn't like for starters putting 40
million dollars towards improving public
transit around the new stadium so what's
a city about to lose its sports teams to
do maybe it's time to take from the
example of the Green Bay Packers and FC
Barcelona both of which are owned by the
residents of their cities so does anyone
in Oakland have 1.3 billion to keep the
Warriors home